all right that's a little better
low tech in it today don't have the
energy to put the green screen up but
game of thrones season 5 episode 7 the
gift up front right off the bat it's
better than the last episode it's quite
a bit better than the last episode that
doesn't necessarily make it a great
episode it still feels uh a little bit
more wheel spinny than i think it should
this far into the season but stuff
happens things that happened didn't tick
me off we're getting to that point in
the season where i can't really talk
plot at all because it's all anything
that i bring up is gonna spoil stuff
that happened earlier in the season but
what's going up at the wall is very much
a natural progression of what's going on
up to that point samwell's gotten some
good stuff and he's really growing on me
he could have really felt burdensome and
very tacked on and forced sort of
sidekick-ish i i really do like him at
this point down in king's landing we get
some more cool stuff with elena tyrell
and also it's worth pointing out while i
don't love all of the sparrow plotline
stuff that's going on the high sparrow
himself i like a lot jonathan price
gives a fantastic performance in just
how different this character is from
pretty much anybody who's been in king's
landing up to this point it makes his
interactions with any character just
that much more interesting because it's
it's stuff we just haven't seen he puts
characters into situations and makes
them deal with things that they're just
not used to dealing with and that's cool
that said the overall sort of plot arc
with the sparrows and what's going on
with them is
exactly what i thought it was going to
be it's very predictable here's an
interesting thing i realized that i at
this point
i kind of like
tomen lannister and also his sister
who's over in doran whose name i can't
even remember but i'm actually kind of
liking those characters which is
surprising to me i mean tolman made my
worst characters list i wouldn't put him
on him there now there's just something
about the youthfulness and i guess to a
certain extent i can even say that how
naive they are but there's just a
sincerity and an unsulliedness to those
characters and given how tainted most of
the characters in this world are it's
kind of nice it's kind of refreshing
winterfell i'm feeling very mixed about
in terms of fallout of what happened at
winterfell which it was a lot of the
stuff that i didn't care for in the last
episode if you watched my uh spoiler
video dealing specifically with that
event i stand by all of that it does
seem like that it at least is impacting
the story in a way that a similar event
last season never really impacted things
so while i appreciate that i still stand
by everything i said in that video and
that what happened last episode was
still unnecessary at least in terms of
the way it was depicted if nothing else
that said it's nice that it does seem to
have some consequences and sansa again
gets another moment again again only one
moment where she takes a little bit more
control than we're used to seeing her
take and i really want these moments to
start coming more rapidly and to start
adding up to something over in dorne not
much happens but there is a very cool
scene in a jail cell with a character
who i really like and there's a lot that
i like about that scene it buoyed some
characters who were feeling kind of
insequential to me and it also gave me
some time with the character who i
really like anyway so that was cool i
think the one kind of weak part of this
particular episode is marine slavers bay
daenerys again i i can't follow what she
is doing anymore she's she seems to have
really lost her way and i mean that like
for her as a character and also a term
of what the writers are doing with her
it just feels like it's gotten to the
point that they've run out of legitimate
ways to
stop her from just going over to
westeros and starting to tear things up
and but it's still not time for that to
happen so they just
it feels almost like they've stopped
trying to justify her just sticking
around and then she's just
doing stuff that is either weird or
uninteresting it's not a total loss in
what we get over in marine and slaver's
bay and all of that because we do get a
very cool fight scene and sort of the
titular gift and what goes on there it's
something that
we've kind of been waiting for to happen
for most of the season and it's happened
the actual consequences of it happening
i that haven't played out you're gonna
have to wait for next episode for that i
suppose but it's nice that it happened
even though i said this episode was a
little wheel spinning there still were
things that happened it just feels like
half steps instead of full steps in a
lot of ways
but again this is a major improvement
over the last episode and a bit of a
relief for me to be completely honest so
i guess that about wraps things up i
guess uh let me ask you this one for
this time there's a there's a scene and
a character in this episode who
gets saved in he's in a situation where
most of the time uh that character who
was put in that situation would have
died but this particular character was
saved so with that in mind what
character who has died if you could only
save one if you could go back and save
only one character who has died over the
course of the show who would it be and
why whatever your thoughts on the matter
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned